armelle charrier où en est-on ce matin
d'évacuation des civils à marioupol et
du repli stratégique russe vers le
donbass qui avait été annoncé oui alors
on est toujours en attente sans fait de
cette évacuation de 2,6 been la date a
été reportée à aujourd'hui on guette un
peu heure par heure comment est-ce que
cela se passe on sait que le le
dispositif d'encadrement croix rouge et
hcr pour avoir du coup un droit
international qui met à l'abri qu'il ya
des belligérants est toujours là hier ce
qu'on a vu aussi c'est qu'il ya eu
toujours des combats en fait à marioupol
alors évidemment de la part de l'armée
russe mais il faut aussi pour être
honnête rappelé qu' on décale dans une
ville où il ya des combats où il ya du
coup les ukrainiens aussi qu'ils se
battent ainsi que des miliciens et que
lens est toujours dans ces moments qui
sont des moments quasiment de chute de
ville que les grands mercenaires à ce
moment là et c'est de partir parce
qu'ils veulent se replier ailleurs on a
eu l'occasion de le voir par exemple
régulièrement en syrie ça c'est pour le
premier point deuxième point sur toute
la région du donbass on est
classiquement sur un repli de vladimir
poutine sur ces régions là je dis
classiquement parce qu'on sait que c'est
ce qui l'intéressait et que donc ce
qu'il veut ce qui peut prendre en
tenaille en fait l'armée ukrainienne qui
résistent et qu'une fois qu'il aura
récupéré marioupol ça lui donnera en
fait une ligne d'accès par l'arrière en
fait de ses troupes
vladimir poutine qui durcit le ton qui
menace les européens de couper
l'approvisionnement en gaz s'ils ne
payent pas un rouble à partir de quand y
at il de quoi un risque de pénurie pour
les ménages et les entreprises
européennes et notamment françaises
alors le risque il est très important
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on imagine parce
que si l'on en croit l'allemagne il y
aurait en ce moment des discussions sur
le fait que l'année prochaine puisque la
froid sera l'année prochaine on
demanderait à aux bâtiments publics
d'avoir un température à 15 degrés ça
veut dire qu'il faudra mettre un pull
pourquoi les bâtiments publics parce
qu'ils sont sous administration de
l'état et ça vous fait donc le
différentiel entre le fait qu'on gardera
le gaz pour les privés pour les
particuliers pour pas que les gens aient
froid chez eux mais en revanche ça veut
dire qu'on réduira dans certains
endroits
comment c'est aussi par les entreprises
ceux qui ne seront pas touchés de toute
manière ce sont les hôpitaux ce sont les
écoles c'est tout là où ça fonctionne
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya ce risque
là parce que effectivement les
approvisionnements ne sont pas toujours
compensées s'il n'y a plus de gaz russe
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
racheter du gaz de schiste américain
mais ça veut dire que ce sera plus cher
ça veut dire que les terminaux sont
ailleurs ça veut dire que ça arrivera
par bateau qu'il faudra regarder filière
et c'est donc tout ça et de toute
manière plus compliqué c'était une vraie
arme qui avait à sa disposition de la
dîmière poutine il ne l'avait pas pour
l'instant utilisé parce qu'il préférait
effectivement garder le cours de
l'argent et se continue à s'enrichir en
vendant son gaz est là aujourd'hui on
est passé dans l'étape d'après qui
montre d'ailleurs havrais énervement de
la part du président russe parce qu'on
sait très bien que s'ils arrivent à
prendre une position parallèle il va
définitivement se retourner vers la
chine et vers l'inde pour avoir du
commerce parce qu'il perdra le marché
européen merci beaucoup armelle charrier
pour votre décryptage merci à vous